salut les menthe à l'eau aujourd'hui je
suis avec romain henry est ce que roman
rien c'est qui c'est lui c'est lui et de
temps en temps romain henry m'a vite à
manger chez lui le soir c'est arrivé
deux fois une fois je sais rien de
calculé le d r d ce que j'ai déjà invité
à manger mais oui mais oui
vas-y à une fois une frite est revenu
et je crois que c'est cette fois là où
on avait commencé à parler de faire une
vidéo ensemble un jour
mais aujourd'hui j'ai envoyé un message
d'après mt revenu de tournée
aujourd'hui tu étais à aix en provence
c'est ça des informations essentielles
je suis en train de me blâmer et là je
viens de réfléchir j'aimerais qu'on te
faire focaliser sur un mot donc focalisé
en fait c'est mieux que dans
l'imaginaire parce que comme tu choisis
tu arrives pas focalisé alors si tu le
prends dans un livre c'est plus simple à
chaque fois si je prends un livre on
peut penser le choix n'est le livre
parker ou ceci ou cela donc on va faire
un truc hyper clinique étape par étape
que ce soit le plus aléatoire possible
que ce soit influencée par quoi que ce
soit ça c'est ma bibliothèque c'est la
bibliothèque du suspense tout le monde
aimerait savoir quelles sont ses livres
de temps en temps j'en prends et j'en
parle sur la chaîne tu vois j'ai pas un
fonds vers ces mêmes rêves et de
rêveries mon cas je te propose
comprennent chacun un livre moi je te
dis ce qu'il va se passer quand même
qu'on pense pas que j'adapte en fonction
de ton choix avec mon livre on choisir
un numéro de page avec ton livre on
choisira un mot comme ça c'est toi qui
choisis le livre duquel sera issu un mot
d'accord ok choisi un livre dont on
choisit aussi gaston leroux le fantôme
de l'opéra a trop bien
trois minutes pour comprendre la grande
théorie du big bang ça donne envie de
les relier en fait que tu le tiennes
mais ça c'est un truc ça me fait souvent
quand quelqu'un de mon empreinte et un
livre que j'ai pas lu depuis des années
je fais maintenant je comptais le relire
bientôt tissu c'est pas vrai dit au
musée comme ça quoi ça c'est le fantôme
de l'opéra hockey qui a été écrit par
gaston leroux qui est né en 1868 et moi
en 1927
ce ne sont pas des infos que je connais
elles sont marquées ici on va s'en
servir comme c'est un bon pavé pour
choisir un livre otages par contre il
m'a pas l'air d'avoir énormément de
pages quand même dans celui-là ouais tu
va choisir un numéro 10 h pour ça pour
ça c'est simple tu feuillette tu vois tu
t'arrêtes à une page tu vas me plaît et
tu lis le numéro de la page à page 443
d'accord par contre y'a pas il ya moins
de 200 pages feuillette dans plutôt
plutôt dans le début tu ouvres et sûrs
faire ça va tu retiens le numéro de page
dans ta tête tu ne dis pas ça arrache
donc tout comme sa pile poil pas une
page où tu veux tu vois une poche tac
talus talent est fermé ouais c'est bon
ok si c'est une page comme ça par contre
tu me bats tu choisis un mot ici tu vois
oui des fois il ya des pages comme ça ok
puis sinon tu prends le titre ouais on
fait ça a marché qu'est ce t'en penses
oui ok alors alors attends je récapitule
je récapitule parce que la scène en
train de partir n'importe comment
donc tu as choisi un livre pour
focaliser sur un mot j'ai choisi un
livre sur lequel tu allais prendre un
numéro de page au hasard tu as pris un
numéro de page au hasard et que tout
qu'il connaît du coup tu vas ouvrir le
livre que toi tu as pris à cette page là
au hasard comme ça on est sûr que t'as
pas de complices et c'est peut être pour
ça que aléatoire tu vois ces cliniques
je regarde pas tac tu lis le titre dans
ta tête si c'est une page à titre si
c'est une page double page lit la
légende l'affairé j'en sais rien c'est
bon ouais tu referme
ok ok tu a confirmé ouais cool je prends
bleus craque ça marche est-ce que le
premier mot du titre est un article un
mot cours non non c'est un vrai mot un
vrai m'ont vraiment d'accord ok parle de
l'aller 1-1 une idée ok c'est possible
mais ça bouge pas est-ce que le premier
mokhtar en tête et un lomo ouais ok je
vais essayer de trouver la première
lettre
ok pour ça c'est simple je te regarde
vous pouvez regarder en même temps alors
c'est très dur pour moi sur un comédien
parce que ça a l'habitude de truquer un
peu ses émotions
en bref c'est vrai nom mais je vais
essayer d'être le plus je pense à la
première lettre
ça peut être une consonne ou une voyelle
hockey à consonnes tu as vraiment bouger
la tête c'est une consonne c'est correct
ok ça peut être a b c d e f g h i j k je
les passais c'est quand même ok f
ok ils m'énervent déjà on sait que on
sait que c'est un livre qui parle du
cosmos et c'est donc le titre forcément
doit en parler ouais ok est ce que tu es
capable de trop présenté par image ce
que veut dire le titre apparemment non
d'après ok c'est pas genre
une machine à laver bleus cancellara ce
n'est pas évident à identifier ok
visuellement
dommage je cherche comment je vais
trouver en prenant des techniques un peu
inhabituel ok je sais tu vas prendre mon
poignet d'accord et dans ta tête sans me
faire bouger le poignet tu vas imaginé
que tu écris de titres en majuscules ok
d'accord
par exemple après le f tu ferais quelque
chose d'autre tu vois j'ai une
résistance ici tu partirais dit si c'est
ça ouais ok d'accord c'est très très
long c'est quand même elle sera très
long ok j'ai résisté parce qu'au début
je pensais que tu allais comment faisait
que la première l'allaitement suivaient
pas le mot complet ok
après le mot complet il yad'autres ou
wii que j'ai pas forcément beaucoup ok
sylvie faucheux les airs mais je sais le
titre complet quoi ouais si je dis que
la deuxième lettre c'est un art est-ce
que j'ai bon ouais oui ok alors deux
solutions sur j'essaye de trouver le mot
en entier soit j'essaie de retrouver ta
page dans le livre tu préfères quoi voir
le mot ce serait plus simple pour moi
parce que comme j'ai déjà deux lettres
j'ai quick à faire parler oui d'accord
ok est ce que je vais dire des mots et
toi tu vas juste concentré quand ça rime
dans ta tête tu dis ça rime d'accord ok
par exemple je dis tiens si ton mot fini
en lien dans ta tête tu dis ça rime
quand ça rime pas du dernier ok donc
chiens chats moutons factice électrique
c'est à bouger un peu sur les flics
hockey fantasmagorique célèbre foutaises
umb était au ralenti boyer les affaires
le mec il serait pas mentir je
ressentais rien j'ai quelque chose
j'aimais ça comme ça parce que tu peux
me dire s'il te plaît ken boothe avait
en tête
fantastique fantastic merci mec
fantastique fantastic étude sur du titre
en entier ou pas eu je croirais
fantastique qu'est ce qui pourrait
mettre fantastique
tu es dans le milieu du livre donc on a
déjà abordé toutes les bases font donc
leur fantastique
le fantastique chemin du big bang ou
fantastiques qui sortent vraiment pas
loin parce que c'est plus facile à
imaginer en fait c'est donc le big bang
c'était top
qu'est-ce que quelle trace d'un stick
naissance du big bang non qu'est-ce
qu'on a encore comme comme trace du big
bang de nos jours la leçon oued ont
essayé c'est un fantastique échos du big
bang est bien fier voilà c'était un peu
laborieux par exemple moi même parce que
c'est hyper difficile alors est ce que
ça te plaît est ce que ça t'a plu ouais
carrément regarde moi je paye et les
médecins c'est surtout le fbi ont dit
comment tu as trouvé le f
j'ai trouvé vite mais tu pourra le
revoir de la vidéo d'agrumes un à 17h
elle sort demain
j'attends même pas tu vois c'est comme
ça et là on s'en rend moins compte mais
romain henry
il est hyper speed et il a des trucs
hyper drôle là forcément c'est moi qui
te demande de te concentrer donc je te
laisse pas te lâcher mais si vous voulez
voir romain henry en vidéo il fait des
vidéos toutes les semaines c'est tous
les dimanches on est tous les 19 verts
17 17 heures mais à la base il aimait
sur facebook mais il aimait aussi sur
youtube
il comprend pas que c'est youtube qui le
plus important allez voir ses vidéos
regardées six avoue que si ça vous plaît
abonnez-vous évident mais regardez au
moins je vous mets le lien dans la dans
la description et en a combien de vidéos
22 vente bunton de jeunes des jeunes
cathos plus de vidéos abonnés et que ma
famille c'est gênant allez voir ce qu'il
fait le concept c je dis ça je dis rien
qui finit toujours par je dis ça je dis
rien berne taylor ferme ta gueule fort
sais pas d'où lui vient cette voie de
livres mon gars mais alors quatre heures
de train pour venir d'aix ont été
fabuleux il m'a donné plein de café donc
comme c'est vrai regarde y en a encore
là je te les mii dans une tasse à coeur
pour te dire que je t'aime tu vois je te
mets plein de pouce en l'air comme ça
deux pouces en l'air
je sens des messages subliminaux plus
tous merci beaucoup d'avoir regardé
cette vidéo j'espère que ça vous aura
plu merci à toi romande est revenue
juste après la tournée de passer à la
maison ça c'est cool aussi
merci beaucoup n'oubliez pas de vous
abonner si c'est pas déjà fait avant de
partir parce que le mental blog c'est
une vidéo par jour pendant un an du 1er
janvier au 31 décembre donc rendez vous
demain à 17h ciao
m